border agents confirm last week 13
migrants tragically died trying to cross
the rio grande into the united states
heavy rains and high temperatures now
have officials warning folks against
crossing the border former ice director
tom human joins us now you know this
illustrates the risk that these people
uh engage in every time they try to
cross the border illegally into the
united states and yet the biden
administration doesn't seem to be doing
a lot to address the situation other
than customs and border protection
warning after this incident against
people crossing in the high heat and the
extreme weather and this is the only
network talking about it i mean right
now we're closing on 1300 migrant deaths
since joe biden became president 1300
and that's what we know about i was down
in brooks county a few weeks ago and i
did a ride along with the sheriff down
there and within two hours of my excuse
me within four hours we found two dead
bodies and i asked him i said i said
how often this happened he says tom
we're lucky if we find one in five
because by the time they locate in in
this dense area they they've even been
eaten by animals or or they just are
never found in the brush we won't many
in a river we'll never find 1300 is what
we know about and that's not including
like the tragedy in san antonio who had
53 dining tractor trailer the numbers
are historic high and this
administration doesn't say a word about
it and they want to talk about how
humane their policies are it's not
humane when you get over 1300 migrants
dying in u.s soil because you have an
open border which causes the most
vulnerable people to put themselves in
hands of criminal cartels and make this
journey you know part of part of the way
that you fix the problem is you first
admit that there is a problem the white
house seems to deny that there even is a
problem with people coming across the
border this way let's go back to last
monday in peter ducey's exchange with
karine jean-pierre listen here
somebody walks into texas or arizona
unvaccinated they're allowed to stay why
but that's not how it works like we
actually no i know that that's not what
you guys want to happen but that is what
what has happened but that's not it's
not like somebody walks over and
that's not that's not how exactly what's
happening
thousands of people are walking in a day
some of them
turn themselves over some of them are
caught tens of thousands a week are not
that is what is happening
now a lot of people who are walking
across the border are also carrying
drugs with them and there's this big
drug bust in a car in nogales arizona
47 000 rainbow fentanyl pills which look
like sweet tarts or smarties or
something like that definitely designed
to attract children and 187 000 blue
fentanyl pills this is a huge problem
how much are they catching versus how
much is getting in oh they're catching
just a fraction and most of what they're
catching is at a port of entry where
every car is stopped you go through
portable entry every car stop and the
officer is going to make a determination
if you're secondary the car not find it
what what's happening between the ports
adventure because of what she's ignoring
she says they don't walk across the
border well 1.7 did last year 1.7
million and this year marked by award
we're going to be at 2.4 almost 2.5
which is 700 000 more than last year
what's the record and when that many
people come across up to 70 percent john
agents are off the line processing that
causes you know 70 of the board wide
open and that's when they move the
fentanyl across and that's why we have a
record number of fentanyl deaths all
right we got a big problem got to see if
the white house is going to address us
tom i was great to talk to you thank you